foreign
[Music]
what's up friends Michael here to
reminisce about a simpler time the year
was 2013. my cholesterol was simply high
for my age I still necessitated haircuts
and there was a new serialized political
thriller starring an academy
award-winning actor whom we had no
reason to suspect was a sex offender
House of Cards hit Netflix to instant
Acclaim and Amelia Network Executives
had simultaneous panic attacks because
the television landscape had apparently
changed forever Flash Forward a decade
and it's fair to conclude the revolution
will not be Netflix and chilled or
netflixed and chilled is that is that it
I don't know that means have sex right
that's because these days days streaming
services are going through it in June
Netflix fired 300 employees as the
company lost 70 percent of its value
then Warner Brothers announced the HBO
Max and Discovery plus merger sending
the internet into a collective freakout
in the weeks since HBO has among other
things shelved the already film 90
million dollar feature film Batgirl
weathered rumors of looming layoffs and
purged its Archives of many beloved TV
shows hard to believe that just a few
years ago media forecasters confidently
predicted that streaming would kill
television as we knew it but with
companies now firing employees
consolidating their platforms and
canceling much anticipated release as we
gotta ask is streaming on the way out or
has it turned the media landscape into a
Content machine that's too big to fail
let's find out in this wisecrack Edition
did streaming content kill culture
before we can reflect on content culture
and streaming it's worth looking to the
entertainment industry's past as
reporter Brooks Barnes notes Hollywood's
no stranger to Titanic moments of
instant change writing once again
operation Hollywood experiences a
seismic shift in these moments all
accepted facts about people's
entertainment consumption are called
into question and premature eulogies are
written for once beloved forms of mass
media for example when it began
broadcasting in the early 1950s TV
started cannibalizing content from the
then reigning Mass entertainment medium
radio popular shows like the Western
drama Gunsmoke and the family sitcom
Father Knows Best were adapted for the
screen while some of these shows kept a
foot in radio television would
eventually render narrative radio
essentially obsolete though if you've
ever listened to a podcast you know
Audio Only entertainment has re-emerged
as a force and you probably also know
discount codes for mattresses online
gambling and fancy toothbrushes but
network television would barely get its
moment in the sun before mainstream
media started predicting its own swan
song sick of your stodgy NBC ABC and CBS
offerings well Circa August 1st 1981 you
were in for a real trip
MTV is remembered for popularizing the
art form of music videos but importantly
it also helped Drive consumers to cable
television subscriptions I Want My MTV
by 1989 an estimated 60 of U.S
households had cable once seen as the
minor leagues of Television where reruns
and old movies reign supreme cable
suddenly became a real threat to network
television's dominance and by the late
90s it was cutting into its profits
what's more reality TV's meteoric rise
in the form of American Idol and
Survivor coupled with the 2008 writer
strike suggested that network television
was on the outs and mad men's Emmy win
marched the first time a basic cable
television show took home the
prestigious award but cable couldn't
stay on top forever and more change
predictably came although many have
called the early 2010s the Golden Age of
cable by 2013 The Economist was already
asking is Netflix killing cable
television rising to prominence as a DVD
mailer service that attempted to replace
the truly Irreplaceable Netflix quickly
pivoted into video streaming and
original content as variety announced in
2020 cable TV's gravy train went off the
rails when streaming arrived Hollywood
became terrified about Netflix's Rising
cultural dominance and serious film
Ambassador Steven Spielberg campaigned
against even considering Netflix films
for top Academy Awards honors once you
commit to a television
format your TV movie you you certainly
if it's a good show deserve an Emmy but
not an Oscar given how TV reporters
economists and even the creator of ET
himself has propped Netflix up to be a
big cultural Boogeyman you'd think the
company would be too big to fail but
with the recent loss of subscribers The
decrease in market value and the string
of layoffs it's tempting to buy into the
media's preemptive obituary for
streaming arguably though Netflix and
other streaming platforms have hit a
wall of their own making and as some
have argued they simply have no more
room for growth as journalist Louis
Chilton writes financially streaming has
always been coasting by on Vibes alone
you can't build an entire business
around exponential subscriber growth
eventually You're simply going to run
out of new customers rather than eking
out hundreds of millions of dollars in
theater tickets the streamy model means
releasing content enticing enough to
keep current subscribers paying for the
privilege of watching it and ideally
convincing new clients to sign on too
even as the pool of potential recruits
keep dwindling and how do you convince
people to keep mailing in 999 pennies a
month by the logic of streaming services
you start producing stuff to watch lots
of stuff to watch Netflix started
growing its Empire with a budget in the
humble hundreds of millions that quickly
ballooned into 17 billion dollars by
2021. I wonder what 17 billion dollars
would do to the increasing amount of
student loan debt huh Joseph Biden and
the mass proliferation of stuff to watch
renders streaming's rise inextricable
from the overall emergence of the
content industry the content industry
basically includes any company that
produces digital content I.E stuff that
you stare at on your phone when you
could be I don't know like connecting
with humans or something while
rumbling's about the rise of the
industry started in the 90s it wasn't
until the emergence of search engines
streaming platforms and faster internet
speed that it really exploded a scholar
Kate icorn writes content sometimes
conveys information tells a story or
entertains but it doesn't need to do any
of these things to circulate effectively
viewed in this way the primary purpose
for content's existence is according to
Economist Bharat Anand circulation and
that's what distinguishes content from
previous forms of entertainment icorn
notes that the material and aesthetic
aspects of the content lose significance
she writes in the world of content genre
medium and form becomes secondary
concerns and in some instances seem to
disappear entirely this is epitomized by
the streaming ecosystem as Anna Cabral
Martens writes the cultural practice of
consuming video on Netflix doesn't
necessarily translate into experiencing
it as television but rather as content
we can see some of this in the way that
Netflix has eroded conventional
differences between film and television
especially with the rise of binge
watching as scholar and Friedberg argues
the differences between the media of
movies television and computers are
rapidly diminishing form becomes
increasingly secondary to content's
ability to attract the most eyeballs and
of course than to use those eyeballs to
collect delicious data in this way a
piece of content success can be judged
not by saying its message if there is
indeed a message it's defined explicitly
by how widely it spreads consumption is
the entire Point not the happy side
effect it's kind of like a Big Mac right
the point isn't that it's a high quality
Burger but that it's a burger that's
consumed around the world 24 7. because
of this icorn argues that content is the
ultimate expression of neoliberalism in
that it represents a shift away from
understanding cultural production in
relation to aesthetic and material
categories and towards understanding
cultural production solely through a
market focused lens that is to say in
the new content landscape pieces of
culture only matter insofar as they
bring in profit if beauty or meaning is
the mark of Quality Art and enjoyment is
the mark of quality entertainment Bank
ability is the mark of quality content
this state of affairs feels eerily in
line with the mid-20th century
assessment of mass entertainment made by
scholar Theodore adorno in recent
decades he's been fairly criticized for
being a bit of a commercial legend for
his critique of the mass culture and
especially of Classic Hollywood films
and jazz music to be clear both of those
things Rip but when it comes to Modern
streaming series like f boy Island we
think his argument Bears consideration
along with philosopher Max horchimer
adorno conceived of mid-century
entertainment what they called the
culture industry it has a sort of
assembly line where art and
entertainment are reduced to Mere
products created solely to produce
profit as they write a cultural entity
is typical of the culture industry are
no longer also Commodities they are
Commodities through and through in this
way they thought art started being
valued for its ability to sell rather
than its ability to impart a message
illicit emotions or Express an aesthetic
Vision an essential part of this
assembly line logic is that the
entertainment industry recycles the same
storytelling conventions ad nauseum
until the distinctions between
individual works of art become entirely
meaningless and again while we don't
think this applies to say the
improvisational Jazz of John Coltrane we
do think it's a fitting encapsulation of
the streaming industrial complex where
there are seemingly infinite reality
shows about rich people who love fashion
and live for drama or shoot couples who
help people build their dream homes with
an estimated 1600 shows and several
hundred movies made and distributed on
various streaming platforms each year
there's never been more content to
consume and if you're listening
streaming networks why not make it 1601
and give us a shot but the assembly line
logic of it all becomes glaringly
apparent when you consider how a
platform like Netflix generates its
ideas Netflix your greenlit who am I
speaking with specifically the platform
relies heavily on its one billion dollar
artificial intelligence program to guide
its content selection if I was running
things after this clip then it would cut
to the doctor evil from Austin Powers
saying one billion dollars or Disney say
one million see I [ __ ] it up never
mind for example House of Cards a remake
of a BBC program was algorithmically
generated to attract the Venn diagram
intersection of Kevin Spacey fans like
David Fincher and enjoy British
political Thrillers here here we see how
a work of entertainment is reduced to
the sum of its parts rather than say
it's Artistic integrity it's like when
KFC had the Double Down sandwich where
the bread was fried chicken and where
the chicken would normally go was bacon
and cheese and literally just talking
about it I feel my LDL just spiking we
talk about this in our video about why
all Netflix films look the same but it
Bears repeating the result of this AI
content selection has led to the
proliferation of a sort of mutant film
created to take as many box office happy
criteria as possible this is also why we
get a lot of content based on existing
intellectual property whether it's the
million Marvel shows on Disney Plus or
Bridgerton which is based on a series of
romance novels or how about the show
based on a New York Magazine article
about anadelvi or the staircase which is
based on a documentary series which is
based on a real life true crime in case
you missed that one it's a narrative
show based on a documentary series about
a real-life murder that an owl did to a
lady I am a proud member of owl Theory
Nation shout it out in the comments if
you are too the assembly line Lodge of
streaming also explains the rise in
reality TV shows which are significantly
less expensive to produce than
conventional narrative content while
also allowing for other money making
avenues like seamless product placement
take HBO famously the capital H home of
prestige television it's merger with
Discovery and with an acquisition of
reams of reality television is
indicative of just how much streaming
has changed from its days of high
quality programming to its increased
Reliance on low budget reality shows
that are conducive to endless spin-offs
like f boy Gaza Strip F boy emergency
room F boy Alaskan Mortuary F boy cruise
ship stranded at Sea with a disease on
it or F boy pediatrician's office no
wonder that streaming is coincided with
the slow devaluation of mass culture and
the people who make it streaming
services have used their classification
as New Media to deny entertainment
workers Fair pay especially those doing
thankless jobs on film and TV sets
residuals once a vital source of income
for entertainment workers have been
slashed meaning workers ranging from
production designers to lead actors are
paid once for their work rather than
compensated for reruns DVD sales Etc
over the course of many years as in
traditional television clearly these
streaming Industries assembly line of
content encapsulates the ethos of the
content industry and with it the
acceleration of adorno and horchimer's
logic about the culture industry's
cheapening of art fittingly then
streaming's dominance also seems to be
Shifting The Way We view content both
literally and conceptually while
television fans were formally at the
mercy of weekly air times to catch
Seinfeld a car just bashed into a parked
car and sped off right on my block
you gotta follow that car what streaming
services have enabled the consumption of
an entire show all at once as Netflix's
CEO put it we're competing with sleep
the very format of the platforms is
conducive with this Netflix's autoplay
function facilitates endless watching
essentially choosing for the viewer to
continue the next leg of their viewing
[ __ ] it's no wonder then that much of
our entertainment consumption is done
absent-mindedly with the exception of
video games which remain arguably the
most active form of cultural consumption
so Gamers keep on fighting against the
dying of the light as writer Jake pitra
argues in a binge culture the banal
pleasures of zoning out coexist with and
play an increasingly strategic role in
maintaining the Intensive pleasures of
switch down viewing the rising
phenomenon of second screens compounds
the zoning out effect with viewers
dividing their attention between
multiple stimuli also if you have a
boring job and you need multiple stimuli
on Thursdays at 11AM Pacific check out
our stream wisecrack live you can have
it on with headphones and you like act
like you're working but really we're
just hanging out watching videos I'll
probably get unhinged for a little bit
it'll be fun check it out arguably this
is why much of the streaming services
low impact content works so well it
doesn't demand rigorous attention but it
does demand our time lots and lots of
our time I guess it takes time to spot
all the the F boys on the island it's
like it's like where's Waldo except
Waldo [ __ ] and that's the real reason
streaming services aren't going anywhere
because they have a loyal Army of
workers supporting them namely you see
according to adorno and horkheimer the
assembly line nature of cultural
production under Lake capitalism and the
repetition of entertainment's narratives
and forums essentially turns consuming
entertainment into mechanized work they
write Amusement under late capitalism is
the prolongation of work it is sought
after as an escape from the mechanized
work process and to recruit strength in
order to be able to cope with it again
but at the same time a mechanization has
such power over a man's Leisure and
happiness and so it profoundly
determines the manufacture of amusement
Goods that his experiences are
inevitably after images of the work
process itself what happens at work in
the factory or in the office can only be
escaped by approximation to it in one's
Leisure Time in this way while we may
see a long night of streaming as an
escape from the humdrum repetition of
our day drops consuming it becomes
something of a part-time job in and of
itself but hey what else would we do at
that time right we're gonna like hang
out and reflect on our lives and maybe
reflect on our lives in relation to
society and our place in society maybe
we would gather with our friends and
neighbors and reflect collectively
organized to change a society that's
grinding us all into dust yeah that'd be
that'd be random importantly adorno and
horikheimer also argue that the culture
industry has significant ramifications
on our political agency because it's
produced and consumed under the logic of
profit-minded neoliberalism products of
the culture industry typically uphold
dominant social and political values as
scholar Kumar salehi writes for Verso
Chief among adorno's concerns is that in
the culture industry what gets left out
is an understanding not only of the real
mechanisms of power in society but also
the possibility that those mechanisms
could be changed submission in the realm
of culture prepares us to be submissive
in the realm of politics this emission
is encapsulated by the passivity we
experience when binge watching as we're
directed to continue consuming and
arguably when we consume content
consistent with dominant political
realities we're being primed to quietly
accept them or the opposite I.E we're
watching a show with relatively smart
social or political values but this only
furthers our desires to sit in place and
watch all 10 episodes so either way we
aren't going outside while art has long
been seen by artists and philosophers as
a vital means of questioning dominant
values or offering Alternatives content
tends to conform to them that's true
whether it's glamorizing extreme wealth
emphasizing the social importance of sex
appeal or reminding us that what really
matters is home ownership and the
nuclear family in this way because of
the logic behind its production it's
very difficult for content to be truly
subversive unless it's us we can we
figured it out upon reflection it's
surprising that streaming ever attempted
to be any anything other than an
assembly line of Capital C content to
facilitate endless consumption the early
years dominated by Prestige shows and
indie films simply don't fit the logic
of the way we consume content the kinds
of reality shows and docu-series and
carbon copy rom-coms that have
proliferated in recent years into
significant dismay are far more fitting
to the zoned out venging that the medium
of streaming encourages so streaming
isn't dead but it's arguably a zombified
version of itself stuck in a race to the
bottom where no amount of content is
ever enough and cheap utterly watchable
entertainment that foregoes provocation
is King but what do you guys think has
content destroyed culture as we know it
and our streaming platforms the main
culprits let us know what you think in
the comments thank you so much to our
patrons for all your support and do
check out our patreon page if you
haven't in a while be sure to like this
video if you thought it was good content
and thanks as always for hanging out and
watching we'll catch you later
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]